bien donc aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler très personnalité je dirige et je
vous connais pas mais maintenant je
connais même personne par contre je sais
à peu près sûr d'une chose c'est que
vous avez à peu près tous des traits de
personnalité différents et des
caractères différents
donc certains d'entre vous seront timide
certains d'entre vous seront ambitieux
et d'autres vont plus tôt avoir des
profils de type anxieux et la question
qui est posée c'est que finalement en
biologie mais aussi en médecine on a eu
tendance à laisser de côté et a ignoré
un petit peu ces variations
interindividuelles malgré le fait que
ces variations elle voit avoir d
importance
d'un point de vue personnel c'est vrai
que selon votre comportement ça va
changer vos interactions avec les autres
personnes ça va changer votre
intégration dans la société ce que vous
êtes capable de faire et ça va aussi
altéré certainement des vulnérabilités
ou des résilience à des pathologies
donc la question maintenant qu'on va
essayer de voir c'est comment est-ce que
d'un point de vue biologique on peut
aborder ces questions de la variabilité
interindividuelle alors une des
premières choses qu'on va quand même
bien rappeler c'est que cette notion
personnalité elle est pas propre à
l'homme c'est pour ça un petit peu cette
image c'est que en fait dans le règne
animal et ce à tous les propriétaires
d'animaux le savent déjà je suis capable
d'identifier des traits de caractère vos
chiens vos animaux de compagnie vous
êtes capable de dire s'ils sont
sociables et ses jets ou présenté un
premier exemple est une expérience qui a
été fait à nancy dans les années 90 dans
lequel ils vont montrer finalement que
en fonction du contexte social
environnemental
on va faire émerger différents types de
personnalité chez des animaux ici des
rats l'expérience à la pour but
finalement de mettre des animaux
ensemble ils vont avoir accès à la
nourriture ils vont devoir passer par un
corridor
et puis à un moment ce que les
expérimentateurs vont faire c'est qu'ils
vont remplir ce corridor dos ça va
générer du stress ça va générer des
réponses différentes selon les individus
face à ça vous allez avoir un certain
nombre d'animaux qui vont accepter de
plongée finalement pour aller récupérer
de la nourriture
une des choses intéressantes c'est
qu'ils peuvent pas consommer la
nourriture sur place dont ils sont
obligés de la ramener
à partir de ça on va voir émerger trois
types de comportement il ya une certaine
population de rats qui va complètement
refusé de plonger pour aller chercher de
la nourriture
donc à partir de là il va falloir qu'ils
développent une stratégie pour acquérir
dans la nourriture et cette stratégie ça
va être une stratégie on va le voir tout
de suite de raquette
donc on va trouver déjà deux catégories
ceux qui rackettent et ce qu'ils sont on
va dire les transporteurs les
ravitailleurs et dans les ravitailleurs
vous allez avoir deux populations ceux
qui sont autonomes c'est à dire qu'ils
vont chercher leur nourriture et ils se
nourrissent eux mêmes et ceux qui vont
pas chercher l'or qui vont chercher lors
de rituels mais qui nourrissent d'abord
et raquetteurs alors il faut absolument
pas prendre cette expérience comme une
sorte d' analogie avec la société qui
vous voulez il faut pas voir ici
évidemment quelque chose comme les
méchants exploiteurs qui exploite le
pauvre peuple et c'est ce qui est
intéressant maintenant c'est que vous
voyez que dès qu'il ya une condition
sociale un petit peu extrême ou une
conditions environnementales extrêmes
vous allez faire diverger des stratégies
mais cette divergence elle a pour
origine le fait que les animaux
intrinsèquement au départ ils sont pas
tous identiques ils ont des traits de
caractères différents et soumis à une
certaine pression
selon votre caractère vous allez
envisager une stratégie ou une autre
chez l'homme vous avez on essaye de
définir cinq grands critères qui sont
l'ouverture expérience de caractère
consciencieux l'extraversion trois
petits points donc c'est très compliqué
par contre chez les animaux on reste sur
des choses beaucoup plus simples tels
que l'exploration l'agressivité la
sociabilité la prise de risque on va
prendre un exemple par exemple
l'exploration qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on va appeler l'exploration qui
finalement une fonction qui est très
importante pour les animaux mais aussi
pour nous imaginez vous dans un
restaurant on connait tous à vous avez
des amis sur une carte qui peut être
différente tous les jours vous aurez
toujours quelqu'un qui prendra toujours
exactement la même chose le hamburger
avec les frites il ya des gens qui vont
changer
ils vont prendre les nouveaux plats du
jour ils vont tester donc la première
personne finalement c'est quelqu'un qui
exploitent
c'est quelqu'un qui sait ce qu'il veut
elle a déjà testé
y'a pas de surprise on exploite nos
informations et on y va
la deuxième personne celle qui va
changer tous les jours et plutôt du type
explorateurs c'est à dire que vous il ya
de l'incertitude dans votre
environnement vous prenez de
l'information chez les animaux c'est
beaucoup plus important puisque la
finalement va voir ces questions qui se
posent
continuellement par exemple pour l'accès
aux ressources un animal qui a trouvé
une ressource de nourriture il doit en
permanence se poser la question savoir
s'il doit continuer à l'exploiter où
aller explorer pour trouver une autre
source de nourriture pour que quand la
première sera fini il soit pas
complètement perdu
imaginez un instant que vous pouvez
mesurer donc ce trait de caractère dans
une population ici doha ce qu'on va voir
c'est effectivement une distribution
autour d'une valeur moyenne
et puis quand on regarde
individuellement par exemple bob et joe
bob en apparence il est moins
explorateurs que joe vous pouvez vous
dire c'est du bruit c'est à dire que ça
c'est de la fluctuation aléatoire et
c'est donc pour répondre à cette
question on refait l'expérience est en
fait tous les jours ce qu on va
s'apercevoir c'est que baume il est
moins explorateurs que joue tous les
jours
et puis si on change le contexte on va
s'apercevoir que bob même dans un
contexte où il faut augmenter
l'exploration mahboob il va augmenter
son exploration mais il restera moins
explorateurs que jo c'est ça qu'on va
appeler un trait de personnalité
c'est à dire une différence pas bhl
entre les individus en permanence
finalement l'individu sera moins
explorateurs qu'un autre ça pose des
contraintes sur les systèmes parce que
ça veut dire finalement que on a des
limites
alors bobee les explorateurs que john
qui sera jamais capable d'atteindre le
niveau de jo medjo paradoxalement il
sera moins exploitants que bob quand on
aura besoin d'exploiter
ça veut dire qu'on est tous dans une
gamme de fluctuation et qu'on a des
limites du comportemental autre chose
que je vous montre ici c'est que en fait
on a un certain nombre de traits de
caractère qui sont corrélés les uns avec
les autres donc typiquement par exemple
chez les souris ou les rares ce qu'on va
retrouver c'est que le caractère
d'exploration est très liée au niveau
d'activité chez d'autres animaux vous
trouverez l'exploration par exemple liés
à l'agressivité
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des syndromes
comportementaux et sa caractérise une
espèce donc la question qui se pose
c'est de savoir quelles sont quelle est
la source de ces variations moi je suis
neurophysiologiste c'est à dire que la
source de ces variations m'intéresse je
vais la mettre plutôt au niveau des
fonctionnement des réseaux nerveux donc
aujourd'hui on est capable d'analyser lé
fonctionnement du cerveau avec beaucoup
de technique d'imagerie
d'électrophysiologie chez l'homme et
chez les animaux et je vous montre ici
c'est une image du cerveau d'une souris
où l'on va voir en fait la mise en place
de certaines structures donc ici par
exemple voyez là où des structures très
bien organisés qu'on appelle les grands
axes fondamentalement tous les cerveaux
sont différents les uns des autres
en fait il ya plusieurs sources et
raison à cette variabilité
alors d'abord on peut se dire que si
jamais pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
différents vous et moi par exemple la
première base savoureuse dire on n'a pas
la même génétique
donc à partir de là on peut pas avoir
les mêmes exactement structure certes
mais c'est un peu simple le deuxième
élément au fait qu'il joue énormément
dans la construction d'un cerveau c'est
les phases de développement je vous
rappelle qu'on part d'une cellule et
puis qu'on arrive finalement un individu
multicellulaires très complexe et le
cerveau c'est 1 milliards de cellules
connecter de manière très précise les
unes avec les autres
alors au cours du développement les
cellules finalement elles vont réussir
elles vont bien se mettre pour réaliser
les grandes structures telles que les
cortex hippocampe le cervelet et c'est
donc ça c'est conserver d'un individu à
l'autre mais par contre si je regarde
précisément les connexions par exemple
de ces cellules ici vers où elle
projette entre deux individus je vais me
jeter des différences statistiques
le système ne peut pas reproduire
exactement tout le temps la même chose
c'est une source de variations
importantes la troisième source de
variations qui est laid arrive tout au
long de la vie c'est la plasticité nos
cerveaux sont des structures imminent
plastique éminemment plastique ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que quand vous avez une
expérience quand vous apprenez quand
vous êtes soumis à un stress quand vous
êtes soumis à des modifications
environnementales vos structures vont
s'adapter
vous allez avoir des modifications à la
fois anatomique dans les connexions fine
entre les neurones ce qui va permettre
entre autres vos apprentissages mais
aussi un certain nombre d'adaptations et
enfin je dirais qu'il y en a une
quatrième plus compliqué qui sont l'état
faire que votre cerveau c'est une
structure dynamique avec une même
structure
je peux avoir différents modes de fonds
et ça c'est pareil on va avoir des
interactions avec l'environnement qui
fait que vous allez favoriser certains
états si je suis stressé mon cerveau va
plutôt se mettre à fonctionner d'une
certaine manière par rapport à si je
suis détendu donc tous ces processus là
il met quand même en évidence deux
choses c'est que vous pouvez avoir des
variations discret dans la structure
même du cerveau et par exemple je peux
vous expliquer relativement facilement
finalement pourquoi de cerveau qui se
devrait être identique comme des jumeaux
ne le sont pas tout simplement parce que
les phases de développement et
l'histoire individuelle n'est pas la
même et donc vous allez avoir une sorte
de dîme printing où finalement le vos
réseaux vont marquer toutes les
différences individuelles de vos
expériences
le problème c'est de savoir quelle est
la source de cette variation vous
qu'elle est là
le moteur de ces variations le premier
moteur on a l'impression c'est le hasard
si je regarde mes deux premiers points
génétique développement c'est quelque
chose qui se passe au début de la vie ha
ha et ça pourrait être considérée comme
étant la chose qui vous apporte le plus
de variations et donc qui va définir vos
comportements si c'est ça on va dire par
exemple c'est le hasard qui va
déterminer vos comportements et donc vos
comportements ne sont pas le fruit d'une
adaptation vos traits de caractère ne
sont pas issus de l'adaptation bougez
vous naissez avec un bagage un certain
nombre de traits de caractère et puis ça
va être vous de faire avec clément
l'autre hypothèse
ça serait plutôt de dire que vos traits
de caractère sont issus d'une adaptation
c'est à dire que dans votre
environnement dans vos relations
sociales va y avoir un certain nombre de
choses qui vont intervenir qui vont
changer vos habitudes vos traits de
caractère vaugh mécanisme de prise de
décision et ça ça va changer votre
personnalité et donc dans ces cas là
votre personnalité elle est adaptée à
l'environnement c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose pour étudier ce genre de
choses on développe dans les
laboratoires ce qu'on appelle maintenant
des mini société c'est à dire qu'on va
développer des grands environnements
d'en coller on va laisser les animaux
vivre pendant très longtemps
et puis on a les outils technologiques
maintenant qu'ils nous permettent
finalement de films et si les
comportements de ces animaux en continue
d'analyser finalement
leur position en utilisant des puces
rfid en utilisant de la vidéo et puis on
va laisser ces animaux dans ces
environnements et puis comme on peut le
faire des populations d'hommes en fait
on va analyser en continu ces
environnements et essayer de voir quels
sont les caractéristiques de chaque
individu
donc en faisant ça on va pouvoir avoir
un suivi individuel d'une souris sur
plusieurs mois et donc véritablement
tracer une sorte de carte individuelle
de chaque animal alors en plus je vous
montre ici dans ces environnements l'a
donc dans laquelle on n'a pas à
intervenir où on propose à la souris un
certain nombre de tests cognitifs qui
nous permette de l'évaluer donc on a des
systèmes de portes ou dans lesquels les
souris se présentent elles sont
sélectionnées une par une et puis là par
exemple elle doit choisir d'aller à
droite pour recevoir une récompense ou à
gauche pour se voir une autre type de
récompense et donc je voulais proposer
ces tests la laisser vivre là dedans et
au bout de quelques mois je regarde un
petit peu tous ces résultats c'est pas
simple c'est beaucoup de données mais
quand on fait ça on voit deux choses
tout d'abord très vite vous vous rendez
compte que les souris développe des
traits particuliers
certaines souris pour être très active
d'autres très peu active elles vont
rester en groupe d'autres vont plutôt
être exploratrice externe au niveau de
la zone de test qu'on propose c'est
l'animal s'il a le choix d'aller à
droite ou à gauche
est ce qu'on fait en général c'est qu'on
met à droite par exemple du sucre et à
gauche de l'eau et puis l'animal on le
laisse choisir et on voit ce qu'il fait
ici on voit émerger deux types
d'individus cet animal par exemple quand
le sucre et à droite il va à droite
à partir du moment où je change de côté
le sucre on voit que très vite l'animal
suit est donc vaste witch et poursuivre
le sucre ou sans se dire et c'est le
comportement à peu près normale et
standards attendu c'est à dire que
l'animal est intéressé par le sucre il
est capable de savoir où il est il le
trac
par contre en face ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'on a aussi une population d'animal
qui elle n'en a rien à faire du sucre ou
de l'eau elle va toujours à gauche tout
le temps
ces animaux quand on regarde leur
comportement dans la communauté ils sont
différents aussi cela effectivement sont
plus explorateurs cela resteront plus en
groupe
et puis ils iront finalement plusieurs
la nourriture que vers l'eau vers la
nourriture solide que vers l'eau et puis
ils ont tendance à moins vivre isolés
les uns que les autres
l'autre différence que je vous ai disais
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on est capable
d'analyser un petit peu les structures
du cerveau de ces animaux est ce qu'on
peut voir c'est qu'il ya des grosses
différences au niveau de certains
neuromodulateurs par exemple la dopamine
qui est un niveau d'activité beaucoup
plus faible chez ces individus en gris
que chez ces individus en rouge jusque
là finalement c'est intéressant mais y'a
pas grand chose de surprenant quand on
met les individus au sein d'un même
milieu
on va avoir une divergence des traits de
caractère et on va faire exploser on va
faire apparaître cette divergence en
utilisant ce type de test c'est un peu
comme les rats plongeurs par contre ce
qu'on peut faire quand même analyse
c'est dire ok qu'est ce qui se passe
maintenant si je prends tous ces
individus par exemple pour un même type
de phénotype si je met ensemble que des
individus gris sur les individus qui
switch
si je fais ça je laisse les animaux
pendant quatre cinq semaines ensemble
très rapidement ce que je vais voir si
une réadaptation c'est à dire que je
vais voir l'apparition d'individus âge
est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
des individus qui avant était capable de
faire ce test en suivant le sucre
maintenant sont plus capables alors soit
vous imaginez
effectivement ils sont bêtes c'est pas
tout à fait ça le sens du test soit vous
j'ai imaginé en fait que dans le social
ils se sont repositionnés les uns par
rapport aux autres ils ont redéfini
chacun leur rôle et à partir de ce
moment là dans ses rôles il y en a un
certain nombre qui ont laissé le côté
exploration pour développer le côté
exploitation et à partir du moment là
quand on leur fait leurs tests même tout
seul et pas en comparaison des autres
mais il continue à exploiter ce profil
exploitants et donc il ne souhaiterait
plus donc ça ça veut dire que
vous avez un certain nombre de
comportements qui sont des adaptations à
votre environnement
si vous avez des changements forts ou
important dans l'environnement
vous allez adapter vos traits de
caractère dont vous n'êtes pas si défini
que ça à la naissance
et puis il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui sont beaucoup plus adaptatif
alors évidemment vous allez me dire moi
ça m'intéresse ce genre de chose
maintenant enfin ça paraît assez évident
de finalement de dire que vous vous
adaptez maintenant qu'elle est la
conséquence pour un certain nombre de
pathologies
si je prends des maladies psychiatriques
par exemple les addictions vous devez
savoir que effectivement il ya beaucoup
de gens qui vont essayer les produits et
tout le monde ne devient pas dépendants
c'est le cas de la cigarette c'est aussi
le cas de l'alcool l'alcool d'ailleurs
est un très bon exemple
vous avez des gens qui peuvent consommer
de manière festive de l'alcool toute
leur vie sans perdre le contrôle et là
vous pouvez vous dire c'est jean lain
finalement sont résistants et puis il ya
des gens qui très vite même s'il
commence à avoir de l'alcool de manière
festive vont tomber dans la dépendance
et là vous vous dites pas de chance ils
n'avaient pas les projets nous n'avait
pas les bonnes 2 par contre si l'on
considère que ce que je vous ai montré
avant est vrai ce qui peut se passer
c'est que lorsque au cours de votre vie
vous avez un changement dans votre
relation
un changement dans votre vie familiale
ce qui peut se passer si vous allez
avoir une réadaptation d'un certain
nombre de vos traits de caractère est
quelque chose que vous contrôliez avant
finalement vous allez en perdre le
contrôle et donc vous allez voir ça
atypique manche et d un certain nombre
de qui vous rouvre des gens qui vont
toutes leurs vies contrôler leur
consommation
et puis c'est un événement familial ou
autres vont basculer dans la mise en
place de la dépendance
donc ce qui est intéressant finalement
c'est de voir aussi quelles sont les
relations entre ces traits de caractère
et des susceptibilités aux pathologies
d'accord finalement on va avoir des
mécanismes de boucles qui font que vous
avez des traits de caractère qui vont
être associés à des susceptibilités par
exemple la prise de risques est associé
justement aux addictions parce qu'en
fait vous avez tendance à essayer les
choses
mais une fois qu'on a commencé à prendre
des produits l'addiction va augmenter la
prise de risque et donc vous avez des
mécanismes en boucle comme ça qui font
que vous allez converger vers des
profils
alors au final d'un point de vue
recherche travailler sur ces variations
individuelles qui semble être quelque
chose au départ qu'on pouvait s'y
trouver du bruit ça nous ramène à
essayer de comprendre un petit peu
comment les individus interagissent avec
leur environnement
c'est à dire comment les individus
changent le renvoyant devant et comment
l'environnement en contrepartie change
les individus
ça c'est le premier point la deuxième
chose c'est faire rentrer l'individu en
tout cas faire rentrer la notion
d'individu dans le mécanisme médical
c'est à dire qu'en fait on doit pouvoir
maintenant avec le développement de ce
qu'on appelle la médecine personnalisée
avoir une médecine qui est basé sur
l'histoire de l'individu et pas
seulement sur des histoires de ce pain
seulement sur un individu moyen est donc
en conclusion je dirais que en tout cas
pour moi en tant que chercheur
travailler sur ces domaines ce travail
est sûre finalement des choses très très
spécifiques sur des souris au fond d'un
laboratoire
ça nous laisse pas très loin de
phénomènes qui sont relativement très
important pour la société
merci
[Applaudissements]